Transcriber: Nazlı Aldoğan
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Özgür toplumlar tehlike altında.
2016 yılında İngiliz siyasetçiler topluma
yalan söyleyerek
İngiltere’nin Avrupa Birliği’nden
çıkmasına neden oldular.
Üstelik yalan söylediklerini de
kabul ettiler.
Bugün İngiliz toplumunun sadece %39′u
Avrupa Birliği’nden çıkmanın
doğru bir karar olduğunu söylüyor.
İşin  temelinde
rızamızın manipüle edilmesi var.
Doğru veriye, doğru bilgiye
erişimimizin önünde engeller var.
Bize yalan söylüyorlar.
Peki ben kimim?
Size niye bunu anlatıyorum?
Ben Can Selçuki,
bir kamu araştırması şirketim var.
İşim veriyi toplamak,
veriyi anlamlandırmak
ve şeffaf bir şekilde sizlere iletmek.
Peki neden bunu yapıyorum?
Çünkü bir çıkış yolu aramak zorundayız,
bir çıkış yolu bulmak zorundayız.
Demokratik hesap veren özgür sistemlerin
toplumların oluşabilmesi için
bir çıkış yolu aramak zorundayız.
Ben de bunun peşindeyim aslında.
Bugün doğru veriye ve bilgiye
erişimimizin engellenmesi
özgürlüğümüzü neden tehdit ediyor
ve bu niye hepimizin derdi olmalı,
size bunu anlatmaya çalışacağım.
Ez cümle, sonda söyleyeceğimi
baştan söyleyeyim,
bilgiyi demokratikleştirmek durumundayız.
Peki veriyi demokratikleştirmek ne demek?
Veriyi ulaşılabilir kılmak,
veriyi anlamlandırmak
ve şeffaf bir şekilde
kitlelerin erişimini sağlamak demek.
Bugün günlük bazda 2 buçuk milyon
kentilyon bayt veri üretiliyor.
Dünyada üretilen bütün verinin %90′ının
geçtiğimiz 2 sene içerisinde üretildiği
hesaplanıyor.
Başka bir hesaba göre,
2030 yılına geldiğimizde
6 yaşından büyük dünya nüfusunun
%90′ının çevrimiçi olacağı hesaplanıyor.
Bunlar, akli sınırlarımızı
zorlayan rakamlar.
Tabi artık veriye ulaşmak daha kolay.
Onu bilgiye dönüştürmek de daha kolay.
Örneğin İnkalar, henüz yazıyı bulmamışken
nüfus sayımı yapabilmek için
lama kıllarına düğüm atarlarmış.
Bundan tam bin sene önce
Çin’de 12 milyon
hanede yaşayan 50 milyon kişiye
nüfus sayımı yapılmış.
O günün koşullarında bunun ne kadar
zor bir iş olduğunu tahmin edebilirsiniz.
Veriyi üretmek, veriyi anlamlandırmak,
bundan bilgi sahibi olmak
tabi zor ve pahalı bir iş.
İşte bu nedenle verilerimiz, bilgilerimiz
devletlerin, hükûmetlerin,
özel sektör kuruluşlarının,
bankaların, holdinglerin,
büyük teknoloji firmalarının
tekelinde bulunuyordu,
onların elinde toplanıyordu bugüne kadar.
Bugün hâlâ büyük ölçüde öyle.
Ekonomi literatüründe veriye sahip
olmaktan, bilgiye sahip olmaktan
elde edilen güç, bilgi asimetrisi
kavramı ile açıklanıyor.
En temelinde bilgi asimetrisi şu demek:
İki tarafı olan bir alışverişte eğer bir
taraf diğerine göre
çok daha fazla bilgiye sahipse,
buna bilgi asimetrisi deniyor.
Bireylerle kurumlar arasında, bireylerle
devletler arasındaki güç farkının,
güç dengesinin bozulması aslında
bu bilgi asimetrisinden kaynaklanıyor.
Şimdi tabii illa büyük kurumlara,
devletlere veya holdinglere
teknoloji firmalarına gerek yok bilgi
asimetrisinin oluşması için.
Eminim bu salondaki herkes,
hayatının bir noktasında
“Abi, valla bize gelişi bu kadar, aşağısı
kurtarmıyor,” lafını duymuştur.
Peki aranızda hiç bugüne kadar bağımsız
kaynaklardan
gelişinin ne kadar olduğunu sorgulayan,
daha doğrusu sorgulayabilen oldu mu?
Burada bilgi sahibi olmadığınız için
güç satıştan yana.
Çünkü bilgiye, veriye o sahip
ve pazarlığı o yönetiyor.
Sizden daha avantajlı durumda.
İşte devletler, hükûmetler,
büyük kuruluşlar hepimize karşı
bu pazarlık gücünü koruyorlar.
Mesele sadece veriye erişim değil,
bu güç dengesini değiştirebilmek için
verinin nasıl toplandığı,
verinin nasıl anlamlandırıldığı,
nasıl yorumlandığı ve nasıl aktarıldığı;
her aşama çok önemli.
Örneğin 2007 yılında Colgate
bir reklam yayınladı.
Reklamda şunu söylüyorlardı:
Her 10 dişçiden 8′i,
Colgate marka diş macunu tercih ediyor.
Dişçilerle yaptıkları anketlere göre
bu sonuç aslında doğruydu.
Ama bize söylemedikleri şey ise
dişçilerin birden fazla diş macunu markası
tercih edebildiğiydi.
Tabii ki reklamda buna yer vermediler.
Aynı bu reklamda olduğu gibi
benzer durumların günlük hayatımızda
birçok yerde olduğunu hayal etmek
çok zor değil.
Biz geçen sene Türkiye çapında 81 ilde
üç bin gençle bir anket gerçekleştirdik.
Hedefimiz de şuydu:
Türkiye’de gençlerin ülkenin geleceğinden
beklentileri ne,
hayalleri ne, gelecekten beklentileri ne,
bunu anlamaya çalıştık.
Verilen bir soruya verilen yanıta göre
gençlerin %83′ü ifade özgürlüğü olan
bir ülkede yaşamanın kendileri için
çok önemli olduğunu söylediler.
Biz bu sonuca bayıldık.
Çünkü hayalini kurduğumuz
demokratik Türkiye geleceğinde
ifade özgürlüğü vazgeçilmezimizdi.
Fakat daha sonra sorulan sorulara
verilen yanıtlarda
işin pek de o kadar
iç açıcı olmadığını gördük.
Çünkü şunu anladık ki gençler aslında
kendi değer sistemleri içerisinde olan
ifadelerini, özgürlüğünü destekliyorlardı.
Yani kendi değer yargıları bittiği yerde,
başkasının ifadesi, özgürlüğü o kadar da
onların umrunda değildi.
Şimdi bu anketin sonuçlarını eğer
ikinci sonucu vermeden,
birinci sonucu vererek anlatsaydık,
kuşkusuz gençlerin hayallerine dair,
gençlerin düşüncelerine dair çok anlamlı
bir rapor çıkartılmış olurdu.
Mesele sadece diş macunu değil,
tabii ki sadece diş macunu değil.
Verinin bilgiye dönüşmemesiyle
ortaya çıkan asimetrinin bedeli çok büyük.
En büyük bedeli ise rızamız.
Hükûmetler, devletler, büyük sermaye
grupları ile beraber
medyada bize ulaşan bilginin önüne
filtreler koyuyorlar
ve rızamızı manipüle etmeye çalışıyorlar.
Bunu söyleyen ben değilim üstelik
bunu söyleyen Chomsky.
Esnaf örneğini hatırlayın.
Nasıl birtakım verilere sahip olmayınca
pazarlık gücümüz elimizden alınıyor,
toplumlar da çok daha önemli bilgilere
sahip olmayınca
önlerine konulan birkaç seçenekten birine
razı olmak durumunda kalıyorlar.
Boyun eğiyorlar.
Bedeli ise çok ağır, geleceğimiz.
Umberto Eco’nun “Gülün Adı” romanındaki
başrahip karakterinin
uyarısını hatırlayalım.
“Korku olmadan insanları
nasıl yönetiriz?” derdi başrahip.
Korku rızaya giden yollardan biridir,
bu çok doğru.
Ama bilginin kendisine
ulaşabildiğimiz sürece
biz korkudan daha güçlüyüz.
Elbette daha güçlüyüz ama ne pahasına?
Wikileaks belgeleriyle yöneticilerimiz
ve özel sektör arasında hiç de rızamız
dahilinde olmayan kirli çamaşırlar
ortalığa döküldü.
Bu çamaşırları ortaya döken
Julian Assange, bugün yargılanmak üzere
Amerika Birleşik Devletleri'ne
iade ediliyor.
Yani veriye ulaşmak, oradan bilgi üretmek
çetrefilli bir iş, zor bir iş
ve bedeli ağır bir iş.
Fakat bugünün dünyasında yaşıyoruz
ve bu bugünün dünyasının gerçekleri.
Peki bunu nasıl aşacağız?
Benim cevabım
verinin demokratikleştirilmesi.
Peki nasıl yapıyoruz bunu?
Veri ve veriye dayalı bilginin
tekellerin eline düşmesini engelleyerek.
Her birimiz buna zaman harcayarak,
emek harcayarak,
kendi fikrimizi oluşturmak için
vaktimizi harcayarak yapıyoruz.
Burada kitlesel gücümüzü aktive
etmek durumundayız.
Şu ana kadar anlattıklarımı aslında
size temel bir soruyu sormak için
anlattım.
Veriye ve veriye dayalı bilgiye,
doğru veriye
ve doğru veriye dayalı bilgiye
gerçekten erişmek istiyor musunuz?
Üç tane soru soracağım şimdi size,
ellerinizi kaldırarak
cevap verirseniz sevinirim.
Bu salonda bulunanlardan
aranızdan kaç kişi mesela
ücretsiz bir e-posta bültenine üye?
Tamam.
Peki aranızdan kaçı aylık
veya yıllık olarak
bir ücret ödüyor
bir yayına ulaşabilmek için?
Peki şimdi son soruyu soruyorum
ama hiçbir şeye abone olmayan
ve ücret ödemeyenler cevap versin lütfen.
Neden değilsiniz?
Yani pahalı geldiğini mi düşünüyorsunuz
yoksa gereksiz mi buluyorsunuz?
Bu soruların temelinde aslında
daha büyük bir soru var.
Aslında konuşmayı getirmek
istediğim yer de orası.
Konfor alanınızdan çıkmaya hazır mısınız?
Çünkü yeni veri demek, yeni bilgi demek,
huzursuzluk demektir.
Bunu Türkiye’de en iyi bilen
insanlardan biriyim.
Verinin demokratikleşmesi,
ne işimize yarayacak?
Daha doğrusu, işimize yarayacak mı ?
Devlet ve özel sektör devletleri
rızamıza talip oldu.
Rızamızı manipüle etmeye çalışıyorlar.
Bu döngüyü kırdığımız ölçüde
özgür olacağız, müdahil olacağız
ve etkili olacağız.
Tabi yine aynı soru.
Ne pahasına?
Zaman ve emek.
Hem güvenilir veriye ulaştığımıza
emin olmak,
hem de ulaştıktan sonra
kendi fikrimizi oluşturmak için
zaman harcamamız lazım.
Avrupa’da gençlere bir anket yapmışlar.
Tam da şu soruyu sormuşlar diyorlar ki,
“Haklarınız ve iyi bir yönetim için
mücadele etmeye hazır mısınız?
Yoksa iyi niyetli bir diktatörün
sizin adınıza kararlar verip
sizi yönetmesine tamam mısınız?” diye.
Gençlerin önemli bir çoğunluğu,
iyi niyetli bir diktatörün,
eğer öyle bir şey varsa,
kendileri hakkında kararları verip
onları yönetmesini kabul etmişler.
Yani konfor alanlarından çıkmayı
reddetmişler, kolay gelmiş.
Ben bugün tam da bu kadarını
ve daha fazlasını
bilmek isteyeceğinizi varsayıyorum.
Verinin demokratikleşmesi çabasının
bireysel bir arzuya dönüşmesi
gerektiğini savunuyorum.
Çünkü bu talep, ulaşılabilir
veya anlaşılabilir veriye olan talep,
salt verinin çok daha ötesinde,
bize şunları sağlayacak:
özgürleşmemizi sağlayacak.
Popülizmin etkisinden kurtulmamızı
sağlayacak.
Popülizm ile bizi gruplara bölüp
yönetmeye çalışan siyasetçilere karşı,
devletlere karşı, bizi birey olarak,
toplum olarak kuvvetlendirecek.
Demokratik süreçlere katılmak için
gerekli bilgiyi ve özgüveni sağlayacak.
Belki de en önemlisi,
geleceğimizde söz sahibi olmamızı
sağlayacak.
Avrupalı gençlere sorulan
sorunun bir yansımasını
ben de sizlere sormak istiyorum.
Biz geleceğimizde
dışarı bırakılmaya razı mıyız?
İyi niyetli diktatörlerin
iyi niyetli kuruluşlarla beraber
bizi el ele yönetmesini mi,
yoksa gücü, bilgiden gelen gücü
ele almayı mı seçeceğiz?
Bu konu hepimizin önünde
bir tercih ve çok yakında
bu tercihi yapmak durumunda kalacağız.
Biz veriyi, bilgiyi talep eden
kullananlardan olalım.
Rızamızı, başkalarının inisiyatifine
bırakmayalım.
(Alkış)